et
[Musique]
avant de commencer notre feuilleton une
liaison point s'impose beaucoup de nos
téléspectateurs s'étaient plaints des
shadoks disait qu'il était complètement
idiot ça n'avait pas de sens et par
conséquent ça ne présentait aucun
intérêt que éducatif sauf éventuellement
pour les chats les chiens et les
demeurés mentaux hâtons nous de dire que
c'était les spectateurs là avait
entièrement raison et ont fait preuve
d'une très grande perspicacité et
intelligence
un château fut de près en effet quelque
chose de complètement idiot voyez plutôt
[Musique]
c'est que pas de sens non plus bien
quand ça en a un c'est jamais le bon
quant au point que culture éducation
n'en parlons pas il serait donc injuste
d'imposer à ses téléspectateurs le
scandaleux spectacles d'animaux ou
juridique
c'est pourquoi si nous avons cédé malgré
tout devant l'assistance des shadoks
reparaître à partir d'aujourd'hui sur
vos écrans
c'est à la condition formelle et express
qu'il ferait un effort réel et sincère
pour développer leur intelligence et
relever ainsi le niveau éducatif et
culturel de leurs émissions les shadoks
l'ont promis dans la suite des émissions
nous pourrons donc assisté quand les
péripéties de l'histoire nous en
laissons le loisir à l'éducation des
châteaux cours de culture générale et de
culture physique cours de mathématiques
et de mécanique cours de chant
de musique
en
[Musique]
de danse et quantité d'autres art à gré
que nos téléspectateurs se rassurent
donc très peu de temps les shadoks
seront aussi intelligent civilisé et
cultivé que vous et moi et seront enfin
composer un spectacle digne de vous être
présentes va espérons c'est que nous
aurions aimé vous présenter le spectacle
édifiant de château qu enfin heureux
goûtant les joies simples d'une terre
accueillante et hospitalière et un repos
bien mérité mais mais la terre autrefois
ne s'appelait pas en réalité la terre
non elle s'appelait la planète geiger
elle s'appelait la planète gégène parce
qu'elle appartenait à un certain gène et
qui était un insecte
[Musique]
et même c'était pas vrai parce que j'ai
gêne en réalité ne s'appelait pas gégène
non plus étant donné qu'il n'y avait
personne pour l'appeler comprenez par la
suite nous l'appellerons quand même
comme ça pour plus de simplicité ensuite
aulas il n'arrivait rien de bien
intéressant sur la planète
alors pour passer le temps gégène était
obligé de faire arriver des choses il
s'amusait à faire pleuvoir
il s'amuse aussi à faire vente
il s'amusait à ferney g avalanche et et
tremblements de terré ou bien ils
bricolaient sa planète
il mangeait une forêt ou deux à son
petit déjeuner et à midi il venait
facilement à bout d'un tas de cailloux
et encore il surveiller son alimentation
pas trop grossi après midi il faisait la
sieste c'est un après-midi comme ça ou
gégène faisait sa sieste que l'egypte y
arriver
puis beaucoup plus tard les shadoks soi
disant pour conquérir la planète
agen mais geiger
allaient-ils se laisser faire pendant
que l'insecte gégène le propriétaire de
la terre faisait sa sieste
les shadoks et l'egypte y sont arrivés
chez lui quand l'egypte y virent que la
terre avait déjà propriétaire ils
décidèrent d'aller lui parler pour voir
comment on pourrait s'arranger mais il
ne voulez quand même pas le réveiller
pour lui parler d'affaires et ils se
retirèrent très discrète et puis sur la
fin de l'après midi
voilà les shadoks qui arrivent aussi
mais beaucoup moins discrètement avec
leur vend pas et leurs ustensiles
[Musique]
la sieste de gégène et définit les
ennuis commençaient la planète compte
les questions commencent à saper la paix
les gibiers salle et je n'ai pas trop il
se réfugiait dans leurs fusées blindés
il regardait gégène faire du cinéma et
attendait tranquillement que ça se calme
mais les chats ne s'était pas fait
gg les torts des les grignoter les
démons t il au cas c'est comme ça un
certain nombre sans compter ceux qui
l'ont déchets lui et qu'il gardait pour
sa consommation personnelle
si cela continue il n'y aurait bientôt
plus de chats toque sur la tête mais
heureusement
il y avait la lune
les shadoks sont anéantis par l'insecte
gégène mais heureusement il y à la lune
en ce temps là en effet sur la terre il
y avait la lune mais elle était de bien
moins bonne qualité que celle de magna
[Musique]
s'était pas encore un astre ni même une
planète
ce n'était même pas un satellite de
c'était un h1h1 qui se promenait à deux
ou trois coups des au dessus des arbres
et des forêts comme un vulgaire ballon
deux fois ce n'est que beaucoup plus
tard qu'elle le parti vert les espaces
extérieurs dans les conditions que nous
verrons par la suite
vous vous rendez bien compte qu'en ce
temps-là par conséquent aller sur la
lune c'était pas plus compliqué que de
monter au grenier à condition d'avoir
des echets la lune et d'emporter son
manger
alors quand j'ai ne se déchaînaient
les shadoks pourrait se réfugier sur la
lune avec leurs victuailles leur patrie
cuisine leurs ustensiles et leurs
impulsions
c'est ce qu'on appelait en ce temps là
la course à la lune vous devez vous dire
pouvoir aller si facilement sur la lune
quand on avait des embêtements sur la
terre ça au moins c'était une lutte
intéressante
vous avez raison bien sûr mais pas
tellement
cela s'appelle la course à la lune
voyez-vous car non seulement gégène
monge et se traînait mais même ceux qui
traitaient pas eh bien il n'était pas de
son fait obligatoirement parce que quand
la lune était pleine
en quelque sorte et bien elles étaient
trop lourdes est tombée les shadoks en
trop il fallait les jeter et cela
revenait peut même gégène m'en parle
ce qui reste est à ton mode est dépassé
le temps comme il pouvait et quand
gégène s'était calmé les châteaux
prudemment rentrer dans leurs foyers
et puis
ça recommençait et comme ça souvent
plusieurs fois par jour aller sur la
lune au regard de la lune aller sur la
lune descendre la lune monter descendre
c'était exténuant les shadoks allait il
pouvoir tenir sur la terre à ce régime
là les shadoks passent leur temps à
aller et venir se réfugier sur la lune
pour échapper à la fureur de l'insecte
gégène monter et descendre de la lune
dix vingt cent fois par jour c metex
tellement c'était harassant pour les
malheureux shadoks
d'autant plus qu'il y avait le grave
problème des échelles à l'une les
shadoks n'avait pas d'échelle
suffisamment adéquat
[Musique]
il faut vous dire que les shadoks
n'avait pas encore inventé l'échelle
dite intégral que nous connaissons
maintenant ils étaient donc obligés
d'avoir deux sorte d'échelle d'une part
des échelles pour monter et d'autre part
des échelles pour descendre et c'était
pas les mêmes quand on essayait de
monter par exemple avec une échelle pour
décembre
et bien ça marchait pas et même si ça
avait risqué de marché ça aurait marché
beaucoup trop lentement
de même quand on essayait de descendre
avec une échelle pour monter ça marchait
pas non plus ou plus exactement ça
marchait mais beaucoup trop rapidement
évidemment on aurait eu de descendre en
faisant semblant de monter ou vice et
versa mais c'était très risqué parce que
l'échelle au bout d'un certain temps
s'en apercevait alors dans la confusion
les shadoks souvent se tromper déchets
et son regard sur la vie sur terre
décidément c'était pas une vie les jbe
pendant ce temps là regardez gégène
faire de belles flammes à travers leur
hublot mais comme ça risquait de devenir
monotone à la longue ils décidèrent de
mettre de la musique sur les flammes de
gégène pour faire comme au cinéma
[Musique]
oh
et puis un jour voilà que gégé menton la
musique chibi voilà qu'il vient près des
gibiers pourrait coûter de plus près à
faire des flammes spéciales et même à
danser maintenant qu'il avait de la
musique les shannon ça l'intéressé plus
le calme était revenu mais est ce que
cela allait durer
l'egypte y ont réussi à calmer un peu
gégène en lui jouant de la musique
les shadoks en profite pour aller à
l'école dans le cadre de la campagne
d'éducation des shadoks que nous avions
promis au début de notre feuilleton nous
allons en discuter
premier cours de logique shadok
professeur jadot qu au programme les
passoires
on appelle passera tout instrument sur
lequel ne peut définir trois cents ans
en l'intérieur l'extérieur et les
intérieurs et généralement placés au
dessus de l'extérieur et se compose le
plus souvent de nouilles et dont les
trous ne sont pas importants en effet
une expérience simple permet de se
rendre compte que l'on ne change pas
notablement les qualités de l'instrument
en réduisant de moitié le nombre des
trous puis on réduise en cette moitié de
moitié etc etc et à la limite jusqu'à ce
qu'il n'y ait plus de trous du tout tout
et or m
la notion de passoire est indépendante
de la notion de trous et réciproquement
on n'appelle pas soir du premier ordre
les passoires qui ne laisse passer ni
les nouilles ni l'eau on n'appelle pas
soir du second tour dhr les passoires
qui laisse passer et les nouilles et
l'eau on n'appelle pas soir du troisième
ordre ou passoire complexe les passoires
qui laisse passer quelques fois l'une ou
l'autre et quelquefois pas pour qu'une
passoire complexe laisse passer l'eau et
pas les nouilles
il faut et il suffit que le diamètre des
trous soit notablement inférieur au
diamètre des nouilles pour qu'une
passemar complexe laisse passer les
nouilles et pas long il faut il suffit
que le diamètre des trous soit
notablement inférieur au diamètre de
l'eau comme
passoire du premier rang qui nous laisse
passer ni les nous unit lot il y en a 2
200 les passoires qui ne laisse passer
ni les nouilles ni l'eau ni dans un sens
ni dans l'autre et celle qui ne laisse
passer ni les nouilles ni l'eau que dans
un sens seulement c'est pas soir là on
les appelle des casseroles il y a trois
sortes de casseroles les casseroles avec
la queue à droite les casseroles avec la
queue à gauche et les casseroles avec
pas de queue du tout mais celle là on
les appelle des autobus
il est à trois sortes d'autobus les
autobus qui marchent à droite les
autobus qui marchent à gauche et les
autobus qui ne marche ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre
mais ceux là on les appelle des
casseroles il y a trois sortes de
casseroles les casseroles avec la cure à
trotte les casseroles avec lui
[Musique]
le calme est un peu revenu sur la terre
depuis que l'insecte gégène s'intéresse
à la musique jbe il faut dire car il ya
très peu de gens qu'ils savent que c'est
depuis ce temps là que les insectes sont
toujours attirés par les conseils
[Musique]
ajoutons être parenthèse un titre de
conseil le fidèle téléspectateur que si
vous avez chiffre à l'insecte genre gg
votre pain fromage ou vos pieds de table
et que vous vouliez vous en faire un ami
le mieux c'est de lui jouer de la
musique ce n'est pas pour autant qu'il
arrêtera de manger vos pieds de table
aux fins et vos fromages mais à coup sûr
il deviendra votre ami alors il ira
écouter la musique avec vous au salon et
à ce moment là il vous sera aisé que
vous en débarrasser en utilisant les
moyens adéquats
fermons la parenthèse pour g
c'était pareil sauf que les chipies
trouvé que c'était d'insectes absolument
charmant et qu'il n'y avait pas de
raison de s'en débarrasser il parlait
avec lui faire des concerts
comment par quelques fois malheureuse
bon gégène oublié qu'il était le kerry
gégène maître de la terre et de ses
éléments et entraînée par la musique
qu'il se mettait à siffler échos sifflé
comme vous savez il pleut fêtes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'autrefois qui sifflent et aussi pour
faire tremblement de terrre mais joe
team est alors c'était beaucoup plus
amusant loup les jib y virent que tant
que ces gènes seraient le rap la terre
serait pour eux la pum telle planète à
jeu qu'il n'avait jamais
[Musique]
les shadoks veillait
gégène le maître de la terre est devenu
l'ami des jbe les jb lui font de la
musique je gêne déchaîne les éléments
tous les matins gégène privilégie
bouille et l'a fait comme on sait
[Musique]
autrefois c'était dgipi qui allait chez
gégène pour lui faire des concerts à
domicile et lui donner l'aubade à du
tout une information disons que le
domicile de juges n était évidemment
souterrain mais confortable
on y trouvait en particulier il ne
s'agit pas pour le lundi une salle de
bain pour le mardi une pour le mercredi
et le jeudi 2 pour le vendredi et ses
terrains comme ça pour tous les jours de
l'année
venait ensuite une garde-robe avec tracy
broom chapeau rouge aux chaussures home
cravate rouge et parapluies rouges une
kitchenette salle à manger salon chambre
à coucher bibliothèque et enfin une
grande ont très très perfectionnés étant
donné qu'elle pouvait aussi servir pour
sortir avec en plus naturellement un
grenier et un vaste gare de mantes et où
cette chaîne mettait des shadoks qu'il
avait récupéré mais tout ça servait pas
à grand chose car dès qu'il était
réveillé il allait écouter la musique
jpy
il salue peut être tellement qui lui
aussi jouer d'un instrument
[Musique]
l'après midi comme d'habitude il le
faisait sa sieste est là lui évidemment
ils se reposent des tout le monde était
content
les châteaux grands pendant ce temps là
on profitait pour parfaire leur
éducation et mettait sur pied dans fast
plomb d'organisation rationnelle de la
terre pour en faire une planète à leur
groupe
non ce serait comme enfin on pouvait se
demander ce que ça allait donner
pendant que les jeunes s'amusent avec
les jbe les shadoks en profite pour
réorganiser la terre les shadoks
on sait que la terre n'était pas du tout
organiser sion typiquement tout était
mélangé
[Musique]
il y avait de la terre dans l'eau il y
avait de l'eau dans la terre il y avait
même de l'eau dans l'est de los qui
naturellement vous retomber sur la tête
quand on s'y attendait le moins et ça il
ne fumait pas la même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les châteaux qu'au début bien sûr avait
résolu tant bien que mal et
provisoirement le problème à l'aide
d'instruments spéciaux qui ont empêché
l'eau de tomber là où l'on ne voulait
pas mais ce n'était pas très rationnel
ce n'est que bien plus tard qu'il
inventait un parapluie beaucoup plus
perfectionnés qui permettait par tous
les temps de faire tomber l'eau quand on
voulait sur les haricots ou n'importe
quoi c'est ce qu'on appelait le
parapluie arrosoir ou parapluie tout le
temps mais ce n'était pas mon corps
l'idéal
de même il se trouve est excessivement
déplaisant content from any notamment à
la surface du globe
mais pour des contacts sera un trou qui
n'a rien à faire là seulement les
roannais mais aussi des troupes du droit
1-1 dont les coûts mixte et on fait
surtout les trous trop-plein mur
montagne ou beck dollar tous ces
accidents laa ne serait pas arrivé c'est
si la terre avait été rangé le plan
château d'organisation scientifique de
la terre était très simple une place
pour chaque chose et chaque chose à sa
place
d'abord le devin plombier été chargé de
deviner justement quoi arrêter quoi et
de mettre des pancartes pour qu'on sache
pour le reste transporter tous à émettre
les mêmes choses au même endroit pour
une équipe de déménageurs shadoks bien
d'autres il est franchement c'était un
jeu d'enfant la suite nous montrera que
ce n'était pas aussi simple que cela
pour éviter les accidents les shadoks
ont décidé de ranger la terre mais les
déménageurs shadoks n'y comprennent rien
ils ne sont pas assez éduqués et du quai
les chad o'quinn malheureusement c'était
pas une chose facile
les cerveaux des shadows qu'on ait fait
avait une capacité est tout à fait
limité il ne comportait dans tout que
quatre cases et encore c'était pas
toujours vrai parce que bien souvent il
y en avait deux bouchées pour remplir
les cases déjà c'était pas facile et je
la prenais un certain temps c'est alors
que commençait la difficulté parce que
collet case était plein il y avait plus
de place et le château qu on ne pouvait
plus rien lui apprendre si on essayait
quand même alors obligatoirement il y
avait une case qui se vidait pour faire
de la place de sorte que quand shadoks
avec une des plaies voulez apprendre
quelque chose il fallait qu'ils en
oublient une autre exemple si un shadok
avait appris à marcher avec une case et
que plus tard il est a pris trois mots
avec les trois autres cases et bien si
en plus on voulait lui apprendre à faire
du vélo le chat d'oc ne savait plus
marcher en rond comme il n'avait que
quatre cases
évidemment les shadoks ne connaissais
pas plus que 4 mons était gars but zoo
et me
vous comprendrez donc facilement qu'il
n'y avait pas du tout suffisamment d'eau
pour toutes les choses qui existaient et
il y avait des quantités de choses qui
avait le même mot par ses conditions au
plan d'aménagement sadok de la terre
risquait de poser certaines difficultés
une activité fébrile règne sur la terre
les shadoks pour s'y reconnaître ont
décidé de la rangée au mans
[Musique]
ranger la terre dans un sens remarquez
bien ce n'était pas une mauvaise idée
si les shadoks avait réussi ce l'or est
une faut l'avouer des conséquences tout
à fait intéressante pour les générations
futures
notamment ce qui concerne l'enseignement
de la géographie carte de la terre
aurait été à peu près ainsi la montagne
la terre la côte
la mère ordinaire molle et la mer dure
un point c'est tout on n'aurait pas
perdu le temps qu'on a perdus pendant
des générations et des générations a
découvert des contenants plus ou moins
lointain et hypothétique et à faire
l'inventaire de toutes ces îles îlots
archipel qui infestent pratiquement la
sopac nerfs et chaud cause de tant
d'accidents d'avant il n'y aurait même
pas eu besoin de bateaux du tout puisque
on n'aurait pas eu à aller vers ses
rivages lointains ya plus forte raison à
revenir mais combien de marins combien
de capitaines en restant tranquillement
au coin du feu aurait pu s'éviter la
peine de ne jamais revenir
dans ces conditions le métier de marin
aurait été le plus beau métier du monde
tout le monde aurait été marin et la
paix aurait régné
malheureusement ça s'est pas fait et
pourtant pendant des générations et des
générations les shadoks hubert gratter
passait il peut transporter et sans
répit s'acharner il fit défi des rires
et des pipe
saluons quand même ici le courage et
l'abnégation de ces innocentes bêtes qui
se livrèrent corps et âme à cette noble
tâche
tâche d'autant plus noble qu'il faisait
tous ça au péril de leur vie et sans
aucun résultat appréciable tard d'autant
plus périlleuse que le déménagement
s'effectue est bien entendu sans
l'accord du propriétaire
et pour le moment continuer à faire la
fête avec ses amis déjà be mais quel est
il se passer les shadoks dans un angle
soucis d'ordre et d'organisation
scientifiques sont en train de ranger la
tête mais il n'y arrive pas il n'y
arrivait pas parce que vous vous rendez
bien compte que transporter par exemple
une montagne où un bras de mer d'un bout
à l'autre de la terre même en courant
d'arrache-pied cela prenait plusieurs
générations pour arriver au principe à
destination les déménageurs shadoks
étaient obligés d'en porter avec de leur
oeuf
[Musique]
mais ça marchait rarement parce que le
château que neuf n'étaient pas au
courant
il ne savait pas du tout ce qu'ils
transportaient et il repartait de
n'importe quel côté se sent que les
choses n'arrivait jamais ou bien quand
elle arrivait s'était jamais au bon
endroit
et cela durera comme ça pendant des sons
et des sens nous ne nous appesantir ont
pas plus qu'il n'est descend sur cette
lamentable affaire de déménagement ce
fut l'une des époques députés lire les
puces reste ray les plus noires de
l'histoire des shadoks qui en comportait
déjà pas mal
nous passerons donc rapidement sur les
quelques 2600 épisode de notre
feuilleton qui retrace cette lamentable
histoire disons on résumer que grâce aux
shadoks la terre épousa pendant ce temps
là des formes de plus en plus diverse
inattendu et saugrenues et quand on
possède un harrag 3200 douzième épisode
ce jour là c'était le petit matin j'ai
gêne un peu gay sortait de la fête chez
l'egypte y est
il vit la terre creuse sa terre sa terre
qui n'avait pratiquement plus figure
humaine alors saisi la plus terrible
colère
jamais et pourtant là et pour halladay
les shadoks smirt a craint un mois creux
mais encore une fois du rsi et avant le
rallye prises et prirent le chemin de la
lune
les shadoks dans un louable souci
d'organiser la terre l'ont mise sens
dessus dessous
l'insecte gégène le propriétaire ses
vaches et les shadoks fuite vers la lune
[Musique]
et encore une fois la course à la lutte
elle fut son bar elle fut guérie elle
fut terrible elle fut meurtrière parce
que ce jour là comme par hasard des
échelles à l'une ne marchait pas elle
fut meurtrière est vraisemblablement la
dernière car geiger
jura que tant qu'il serait nuit
propriétaire la terre les shadoks me
remettrai plus jamais les pieds alors
des shadoks connurent le désespoir
fallait-il être venus de si loin avoir
enduré tant de souffrances perd du temps
des leurs
fallait-il enfin après tout cela être
arrivé sur cette terre tant espéré pour
aussitôt la perdre être condamné à vivre
sur ce machin ridicule qu'on a appelé
depuis la lune alors les shadoks
connurent la nostalgie ce jour là ils
regardèrent le ciel et ses planètes
n'ont pas comme nous maintenant on
espère on un jour y aller
mais en regrettant d'en être un jour
sans
et au loin on y voyait cette vieille
planète shadoks qui se déforme et un peu
bien sûr mais qui n'était peut-être pas
si ridicule que ça et les gimmicks
pendant ce temps là c'est imbécile a
faisait des faits
[Musique]
les shadoks connurent la haine il
jurèrent d'anéantir gégène et de
l'exterminer alors commence à la guerre
la terrible guerre on dit gégène qui
allait durer des siècles et des siècles
mais qui allait gagner le plan
d'organisation shadoks de la terre a
raté je gêne s'est fâché les shadoks se
sont réfugiés sur la lune
[Musique]
malheureusement la lune était excessif
non pas important comme vous le savez
c'était un match qui montait et son
modèle tourne et à sa fantaisie et de
façon tout à fait l'unanimité
[Musique]
vous allez encore dire tout ça c'est des
histoires aussi bien que sur la lune il
n'y a pas d'atmosphère et vous shadoks
là bas ils n'auraient pas pu respirer
eh bien si figurez-vous qu'en ce
temps-là il y avait de l'atmosphère sur
la lune ça oui il y en avait été
beaucoup plus que vous pouvez imaginer
mais cette atmosphère là n'était pas
dehors comme sur une planète ordinaire
non elle était à l'intérieur de la lune
mais vous allez encore protesté
tout cela ne nous explique pas comment
les pauvres bêtes faisait pour respirer
je pourrais vous répondre qu'on n'a
jamais dit dans notre histoire que les
shadoks respirer mais ça ne serait pas
faire plus à l'origine et des prix plus
aucune portée dans la luz
à moins de petits tuyaux et percer des
trous pour aller respirer un surfaces
comme les phoques mais à l'envers
les chocs n'étaient pas des phoques
alors les aménités panier atmosphère
individuel
[Musique]
non pas de pognon et bien c'est une
vivaient à l'intérieur de la lune
non non vous n'y êtes pas mais puisque
vous voulez décidément encore on vous
explique tout et que vous tenez à tout
savoir
sachez donc et puis non vous saurez la
prochaine fois les shadoks que se sont
réfugiés sur la lune mais l'atmosphère
de la lune est à l'intérieur de la lune
comment dont les shadoks pouvait-il
vivre et respirer il n'avait pas de
petits tuyaux
il ne permet pas d'être ou comme les
forts qu il ne vivait pas l'intérieur de
la lune non des shadoks sur la lune eh
bien il respirait avec leurs pattes une
pâte pour inspirer une pâte pour expirer
c'était même assez pratique étant donné
qu'ils pouvaient faire les deux en même
temps sans se fatiguer on dormira sur et
non il y avait un petit problème mais il
fut très vite résolu grâce à l'invention
géniale du professeur charcot qui a
connu maintenant sous le nom de machine
à dormir debout
mais vous vous rendez bien compte qu'il
n'aurait pas été sain de respirer même
avec les pieds une atmosphère toujours
enfermés alors on était obligé tous les
dix ans dans trois semaines à un mois
deux maîtres l'atmosphère dehors pour me
faire prendre l'air c'était quand même
assez dangereux parce que lorsque
l'atmosphère était partie se promener la
lune naturellement se dégonflait mais
revenons à notre histoire
les ja doc donc avait résolu de se
plonger d'anéantir gégène et de
l'exterminer
[Musique]
mais on ne peut pas dire que la lune
était comme qui dirait une plateforme de
dire adéquat pour exterminer les choses
avec précision d'autant plus qu'avec ce
machin là on les voyait le dire d'assez
loin et surtout la nuit comme par un
fait exprès pour plus de sécurité
l'egypte y avait quand même planté
quelques graines de radars autour de
chez gégène les radars jbe vous le savez
de pousser tout simplement de la terre
comme des géraniums ou du buisson lit et
comme toutes les plantes de cette espèce
là se mettaient à pousser justement à la
proche de la lune c'était président
dudit gégène était aussitôt prévenu
qu'ils agissaient en conséquence il n'y
avait donc pratiquement rien à faire
pour exterminer chèque par la voie des
airs
mais heureusement il y avait les abus
shadow knut la guerre contre gênes est
déclarée les shadoks ont résolu de
l'exterminer les attaques aériennes ont
échoué l'évasion shadow knott vont ils
sauver la situation
les shadoks avaient formé un corps
spécial de cosmonautes ont aussi jugé
c'étaient encore des rires et je lui un
entraînement excessivement intensifs
[Musique]
il n'avait pas de fuser mais j'étais pas
important parce que la terre est en
dessous vous remarquerez que ce n'était
pas comme nos cosmonautes de maintenant
des cosmonautes pour monter mais des
cosmonautes pour descendre on n'avait
qu'à les laisser tomber
c'était très économique est
techniquement très intéressant pour les
cosmonautes salle était un peu moi il
fallait qu'il soit présent durci
l'entraînement commencez donc par un an
durcissement systématique à la machine a
endurci les châteaux clou tout ailleurs
n'avait aucun intérêt à revenir parce
que pour les rendre la vie civile il
aurait fallu les passer à la machine à
attendrir et c'était 100 fois pire
venait ensuite le maniement ta chatte au
cou avait mouchoirs larmes total on dit
gg c'était l'exterminateur qui cloué
l'été ralement l'ennemi sur place comme
il n'avait pas de gégène sous la main
des shadoks volontaires étaient déguisés
en gêne pour que les autres puissent
s'entraîner en toute sécurité
il y en avait de plusieurs sortes
d'abord l'exterminateur à main on avait
aussi l'exterminateur automatique
on allait enfin l'exterminateur à
retardement de loin le plus dangereux
les exterminateurs shadow que vous voyez
là sont seulement des exterminateurs
d'entraînement les exterminateurs de
guerre les vrais était beaucoup plus
petit beaucoup plus maniable et pour
coup plus redoutable gégène m'en parlent
parfaitement tendu aussi armés jusqu'aux
dents
c'est ainsi que la première expédition
aux tiges
n/d sont dits de la lune et les voyons
passer les shadoks dans leurs coeurs
sont et renaître l'espoir de revoir
bientôt la tête à partir de la lune où
ils se sont réfugiés les chats de knott
s'apprête à lancer leurs premières
expéditions vers la terre pour à les
exterminer gégène leur est grave
les cosmonautes shadoks s'avance vers
l'ère de lancement
[Musique]
ils sont armés rappelons le de leurs
puissants exterminateurs anti geiger
jade octobre maintenant prennent place
dans leurs combinaisons spatiales
mais vous allez dire puisque la terre et
de la lune en ce ton là était à deux pas
et qu'en plus il y avait des échelles à
l'une pourquoi se déguiser en
cosmonautes vont descendre sur la terre
à cela on répondra d'abord qu'avec les
shadoks
il ne faut pas chercher à comprendre on
répondra ensuite que les echets la lune
même pour descendre
cela n'aurait pas du tout été assez
rapide
quand il s'agit de descendre les
échelles les plus rapides sont
évidemment les échelles qui n'existe pas
les shadoks note justement descendait
comme ça
les combinaisons spatiales shadoks sont
étudiées pour résister au choc du départ
au choc d'arrivée et au terrible assauts
de l'ennemi
g
[Musique]
vous voyez ici la combinaison spatiale
individuelle munie de tout le confort
moderne
voici la combinaison spatiale familiale
voici la combinaison spatiale de coûts à
long rayon d'action
voici enfin la combinaison spatiale
articulé qui permet dons circle et les
nuits déjà doc toutes sont lancés des
shadows claude sont arrivés bras lancer
maintenant leur capsule cosmique
le module terrestre il leur permettra de
se déplacer en toute sécurité à la
surface de la terre
c'est le fameux costume plus prudemment
silencieusement les shadoks notre avance
dans leur cote beau bus
réussiront-ils à exterminer gégène avec
ça
[Musique]
la première expédition shadoks est
arrivée sur la terre pour exterminer
jugeait les shadoks note avance
prudemment dans leur capsule terrestre
le cosmo autobus
[Musique]
gênes et le jpy tout cas c'est bien
n'était pas dupe il ya longtemps que les
arbres radar du gy be avait détecté tout
ça et pour s'amuser tout en prenant le
thé avec gêne il regardait sur leur
écran le cosmo autobus avancer il faut
dire qu'en plus il avait planté de ci de
là dans les forêts quelques passages à
niveau le feu rouge et passages cloutés
et les chats de knott prudent à chaque
fois s'arrête l'egypte il leur avait
préparé un petit itinéraire de sorte que
le cosmo de plus j'adore fait plusieurs
fois le tour de la terre ait eu quelques
petits accidents amusant en particulier
à l'heure du thé
un jour quand même voilà le cosmo
autobus shadoks qui arrive chez gégène
les exterminateurs attrape gènes sont
mis en batterie gégène est cordialement
invitée à venir six attrapés gégène
malheureusement n'était pas là il était
parti déjeuner dans un sens cela valait
but pour les shadows coûte parce que
entendre normal vous pensez bien
il n'aurait fait qu'une bouchée mais ce
jour là elle ne voulait pas trop se
charger l'estomac et les shadoks nous de
finir au garde manger
[Applaudissements]
évidemment ce n'était pas une fin très
glorieuse pour des cosmonautes mais que
personnellement il préfèrerait ça la
guerre est elle finie
non rassurez-vous d'autres shadoks
suivait
[Musique]
parking pour exterminer gêne la première
expédition shadow qui a été décimée
gégène amis les shadoks note au
garde-manger les shadoks notes n'étaient
pas revenus
mais les shadoks n'était pas inquiet
pour autant
et même ils commençaient à crier
victoire parce que disait-il
ce n'est pas parce que les shadoks notre
ne revenait pas que ça prouvé qu'il
n'avait pas gagné
il suffisait d'envoyer d'autres purent
aller se renseigner
[Applaudissements]
ainsi partie la seconde expédition
[Musique]
mais si d'ici là ne revint pas non plus
et les shadoks ne furent pas plus
renseignés alors il fallut en envoyer
puis d'autres puis donc être s'était
arrêté vous vous doutez bien que toutes
ces malheureux expédition la finissait
comme la première dans le garde-manger
de geiger il est cool et là des jours
heureux en se racontant leurs exploits
en attendant que gégène éléments et plus
ça allait plus le garde-manger
s'emplissait et plus la lune se
désemplissent est alors les shadoks se
mirent à douter le moral baissait on
murmurait la révolte et le devin
plombier subitement eu une idée puisque
on ne pouvait pas vaincre gégène on lui
faisant la guerre nous le vaincrons il
disait en lui faisons la paix son plan
était simple
premièrement faire la paix avec gégène
en lui jouant de la musique
deuxièmement l'exterminer à l'aide de
l'exterminateur
et apprendre la musique aux shadoks note
[Musique]
toutes les expéditions contre gênes ont
échoué les châteaux qu'ont décidé de
l'amadouer en lui jouant de la musique
[Applaudissements]
dans le cadre de la grande campagne
d'éducation des shadoks
nous assistons donc aujourd'hui intrus
ni de musique j'adore
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la musique shadoks colonne de voiliers
consistait en grande partie à faire du
bruit avec n'importe quoi car c'était un
des principes de base de la musique
shadoks pour une oreille bien exercer il
n'y a pas de bruit qui ne puisse être
entendue comme une musique et
réciproquement
le tout est une question d'exercice
c'était assez pénible est assez long
mais il fallait persévérer car c'était
un autre principe de base de la musique
shadoks
c'est en forgeant que l'on devient
musicien cette nouvelle expédition
indigènes plus donc ce que l'on pourrait
appeler une game musical et shadow
qu'avait niankoye évidemment tout un
matériel très moderne de guerre musicale
est totale
[Musique]
oui
je
j'ai réussi c'est à résister à tout ça
est bon il n'y avait plus rien à faire
[Musique]
les shadoks note descendu de la lune
vont essayer de charmer gégène avec leur
musique ils partent à l'attaqué
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais je gêne avec tout cela ne se
montrait pas le plan shadoks avait-il
encore raté
[Musique]
pour reconquérir la terre les shadoks
veulent faire comme les jbe charme et
gêne avec de la musique
les shadoks notre musiciens vont passer
à l'attaqué
[Musique]
mais toutes ces expéditions shadoks
décidément tombé à celle là arrivé comme
par hasard à l'heure du thé au moment
justement où les jib il venait chez
gégène lui jouer sa musique préférée
[Musique]
m
et c'était un spectacle absolument
charmant de voir ces petites bêtes faire
des sérénades arjen est avec lui dans
man c'est le menu
c'est juste à ce moment là que les
premiers ont bu longue portée de la vie
musicale j'adore éclatèrent ces [ __ ]
de fear quinte ou un seul mais un gant
si gros qu'on croyait presque qu'il
allait éclater les jib y avait dû le
retenir et il lui dire écoute gèle les
shadoks ça vaut pas la peine de se
mettre dans des états pareils ça serait
beaucoup plus amusant de les laisser
venir et de leur jouer des tours avant
de les manger définitivement tous de les
mettre au garde manger
or l'egypte y avait un plan un plomb à
base de petites boîtes
les petites boîtes jbe comme leurs noms
l'indiquent était tout simplement des
petites boîtes
une petite boîte cosmique qui pouvait
transformer n'importe quoi ont
pratiquement n'importe quoi et laisser
prendre
c'était très utile pour les voyages
interstellaires par exemple quand on
tournait dans un endroit où il n'y avait
que de la lumière on mettait le côté
lumière vers la lumière et les autres
côté fournissait choix du show soit de
l'électricité soit des rayonnements
atomique soit de la musique du 6e compte
et on pouvait faire sortie ou montrer
tout ce qui n'était pas prévu
tame autre côté qui comprit rien du tout
et les voilà partis dans la campagne
avec gêne et leur petite boîte
mais quelles étaient leurs plans les
shadoks notes sont débarqués sur la
terre pour charmer gégène avec leurs
armes musicales les jib yvon leur jouer
un tour avec leur petite boîte cosmique
les petites boîtes avaient été
soigneusement camouflés dans les
bronches et les bosquets les petites
boîtes jb avec leur six côtés à
transformer les choses étaient vraiment
très amusante canton drac est le côté
lumière vers le soleil par exemple du
côté musique il sortait alors de la
musique soleil
[Musique]
je
si on le braquer sur des légumes verts
dans ce cas il sortait de la musique
qu'à rock de la musique persil ou de la
musique haricots sans fil
et c'était réciproque si bien qu'on
rejoint de la musique haricots et même
en laissant le fils de l'autre côté on
récupère et devraient arriver et sans
fil mais les musiciens shadoks ne jouait
pas de cette musique la puce était bel
et bien de la musique
qu'a donc jouer de la musique cavalerie
de la musique d'assaut de la musique de
choc
m
en amour de la musique contes et les
petites boîtes
jbe firent leur office la musique une
guerrière shadow leur tomber sur la tête
on cuit fine tout par paquet
[Musique]
qu'elle tirait une canne la musique et
un camion leur ton ptc tôt sur la tête
qui ont assommé du même coup une bonne
dizaine ils avançaient pour attaquer sa
tombe et ils se repliaient pour se
mettre à l'abri et ça retombe est plus
belle la vie musicale décimé jusqu'au
dernier
il ne restait plus un gène qu'à ramasser
les débris de shadocks qui traînait et à
les mettre en garde de bourges gégène
élégie be était content il avait passé
une bonne journée
ainsi se termine à la grande expédition
musicale shadoks sur la terre d'autres
descendre et ils ont encore de la lune
après ça
[Musique]
la grande expédition des forces
musicales shadoks sur la terre a échoué
comme ceux qui les ont précédés les
vaillants shadow knott ont fini au
garde-manger
[Musique]
mais depuis le temps qu'ils ont des sens
autun et qui dans des sons des de la
lune et depuis ton qui finissaient tout
son garde manger je gêne avec ses
châteaux prisonniers comme on sait avoir
des problèmes de rangement ci lui s'en
était pratiquement infestés il n'allait
pas lui en mettre aussi dans les
baignoires les armoires les lavabos et
les tuyaux tout était plein de shadow ça
commençait à se détraquer c'est depuis
ce temps là d'ailleurs que sur la terre
quand quelque chose tombe en panne les
gens disent à doit y avoir encore un
shadok de coincer là dedans
[Musique]
comme il ne pouvait pas venir à bout des
shadoks note pour le moment et que
certains même commencé à se gâter il
avait demandé conseil à ses amis les jb
le mieux il pensait c'était encore de
les mettre à paître dont les champs mais
ces bêtes là il s'agit c'est bien du
souci parce que je ne sais pas si vous
avez quelques fois essayé de faire
paître des shadoks nôtre mais ça paie
pas ou quand ça pète ça paie ma vous les
mettez dans un champ et bien ça mange
l'herbe et puis ça mange le chant ou
bien ça mange n'importe quoi ce qui les
rend très rapidement impropre à la
consommation
comme il ne m'est et aucune bonne
volonté pour être mangeable frais il
fallut bien trouver un moyen pour les
conserver avec les plus dodue l'egypte y
firent du pâté des plus maigres salé et
fumé faisaient des chats d'oxo donc
comptablement percée de ci de là de
trous donner un assez bon format mais
même après tout cela il en restait
encore énormément cela les jpy les
emmenèrent chez eux en disant qu'il s'en
occuperait personnel
tous les chats de knott ont été faits
prisonniers avec les uns les gie billon
fait des conserves pour gégène les
autres ils les ont emmenés chez eux pour
s'en occuper
[Musique]
non
l'egypte vit d'abord les tester à ceux
reconnus les plus aptes ont confié le
soin de menus travaux ménagers mais ça
en corse était rien ceux de la catégorie
en dessous était réservée à l'amusement
[Musique]
oh
messieurs de la troisième catégorie des
pauvres est le passé à la petite boîte à
la petite boîte cosmique jbe c'était
encore un nouveau jeu qu'ils avaient
inventé ont branché le chat d'oc sur la
petite boîte et hop ça vous le
transformer en n'importe quoi en briques
en marteau en monuments historiques
éligible parier sur ceux qui sortiraient
après l'essai s'entraîner ou quatre
coins de la terre il n'était pas mort
l'add on remarque qu'ils n'ont
simplement tgt et oui des shadoks
voilà tout ce qui nous reste et c'était
triste quand tu es et les uns dans des
boîtes de conserve des autres changer en
jouet ou un objet ménager tous ces
malheureux shadoks bafouée et humiliée
attendait la rage au coeur qu'on vienne
un jour les délivrer mais là bas chez
eux sur la lune plus un des leurs ne
répondait il était il perdu à tout
jamais pour se débarrasser de leurs
prisonniers les gibiers ont transformé
les chats deux camps confiture ont joué
ou un valet de pied les autres au jeu de
la petite boîte ont été changés en
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
et bien direz vous les shadoks voulait
vivre sur la terre
ils ont ce qu'ils voulaient oui il sur
ce qu'ils voulaient et pendant très
longtemps
ils vécurent comme ça on en trouve
encore des quantités de nos jours des
shadoks prisonnier de ce temps là
malheureusement on ne les voit pas mais
ils sont la transformer en arbre en
cailloux ou objets ménagers apparemment
innocent apparemment seulement parce que
méfiez vous c'est shadoks là ont gardé
au plus profond de leur coeur une soif
de vengeance qui ne s'est écrite raja
mais maintenant ils n'ont plus 2 et gêne
évidemment ou de gy be sure qui se
venger mais ça ne fait rien parce que
tout ce qui bouge maintenant sur la
terre pour eux c'est du jet de celle qui
vous tombe sur la tête exprès parce que
vous passez dessous pouvez être sûr que
c'est une échelle shadoks le caillou qui
dépasse le bec de gascon n'a pas vu
tout ça aussi c'est les shadoks et quand
vous roulez en auto à une allure normale
et que tout d'un coup sans prévenir un
platane c'est pas par hasard c'est un
platane chat doctrine a fait exprès à
terre donc en était pleine mais la lune
elles en étaient vides ou presque
il en était tellement descendu de shadow
cno sur la terre il en était tellement
jamais revu on en avait tellement on
voit dié est renvoyée encore pour aller
voir si les autres avait gagné il y en
avait eu tellement plus de sacs et
pendant tout ce temps laver perry petn
on est quasiment sans le faire exprès
que des shadoks sur la lune il n'y en
avait plus ah si il restait quand même
trois responsables est un imbécile alors
peut-être que ça allait reprendre
mais vous savez on sait jamais après la
terrible guerre contre gênes et sa terre
presque tous les shadoks ont disparu il
ne reste sur la lune que quatre rescapés
que vous connaissez ce jour là encore
une voix les shadoks se retrouvèrent au
bout d'incroyables efforts de
souffrances et de sacrifices
là d'où ils étaient partis c'est à dire
pratiquement nulle part car on ne peut
pas dire que la lune soit un quelque
part est leur seul espoir en somme
c'était de savoir que d'autres efforts
d'autres souffrances et d'autres
sacrifices les amèneraient évidemment au
même endroit mais il ne se plaignait pas
car tel était le but
pour leur destinée il venait de nulle
part et c'est là qu'ils allaient mais il
fallait quand même y aller
ce jour là les shadoks ce contest il
restait en tout et pour tout sur la lune
un chef shadoks vois un devin plombier
un vieux cosmo autobus un professeur
shadow qu une pile de détritus et la
population que vous voyez rassemblés ici
elle n'était pas très très peuplée la
population elle n'était pas non plus
très très très le malheureux shadoks
population n'était malheureusement pas
comme on dit en possession de moyens
intellectuels parfaitement nombre disons
plutôt qu'il était en parfaite
possession de moyens intellectuels
exceptionnellement ta normaux c'est lui
qu'on avait surnommé autrefois
l'irrécupérable c'est vous dire
il fut nommé ministre de la population
est aussitôt sommé de faire son devoir
de population qui est deux populaires
pondre des oeufs pour les shadoks en
principe vous vous souvenez c'était
facile
il suffisait de compter jusqu'à 4 mais
celui là malheureusement n'était pas
assez éduqué au début du contest il
recommençait et ça donnait des yeux tout
à fait impropre à la population à la fin
quand même ils s'y étaient mis mais cela
me prenait tellement de temps un
repeuplement shadoks intensifs et massif
était totalement impossible n'est shadow
coup semblait avoir une idée
le dernier chat d'oc a été nommé
ministre de la population il est chargé
de pondre des oeufs de façon intensive
mais il n'est pas assez éduqué le chat
d'oc population dans son petit ministère
ça lui prenait quand même pas mal de
jours pour compter jusqu'à 4 et pondre
un oeuf
alors la direction s'impatienter jadot
pour essayer d'augmenter le rendement
était en train de mettre au point un
truc spécial qui permettrait avec un
ministre de pondre 2 et pourquoi pas
trois ou même peut-être plusieurs eu moi
même temps à lapoutroie la maison que
était délicate mais le produit lui-même
et des garanties sans danger à quelques
détails
[Musique]
est-ce que ça allait marcher
- mois la direction excuses attendaient
l'heure de la ponte du ministre peu à
peu approché mois eh bien oui ça
marchait première fois il entendit deux
à la fois épique un ebit de la lune se
couvrit d'un grand manteau 2 du chat
d'oc et quand le temps fut venue des
premiers commencèrent à vouloir avec
l'or
ça y était il était sauvé l'espoir
renaissait population shadoks repartait
une population de shadocks tout neuf qui
partiraient vainqueur cette fois à la
conquête de la terre et qui sait
peut-être même aussi de l'univers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jadot qu à trouver un moyen pour contre
plusieurs jeux à la fois les premiers
shattock de la nouvelle génération
lunaire vont éclore en attendant cet
heureux événement nous vous invitons à
assister aux cours de faux logiciels
professeur shadow co d'une façon
générale toute offre se compose de trois
parties l'intérieur l'extérieur et
l'entre-deux
il faut savoir que l'intérieur et
l'extérieur sont en réalité une seule et
même chose quand on pond un oeuf normal
en effet vous avez sans doute remarqué
qu'il est souvent d'usagé de l'intérieur
se transforme petit à petit en autre
chose qui varie selon les cas mais qui
dépendent le plus souvent de la
composition de l'extérieur l'expérience
nous prouve que si l'on à un extérieur
en poule par exemple mais simplement
disposer autour d'un oeuf l'intérieur se
transforme petit à petit en extérieur
ceux qui disent que l'intérieur et d'un
équivalent à l'extérieur et nous
autorise à énoncer de nouvelles
définitions suivantes il noté toute
offre se compose de deux parties
l'extérieur est l'antre 2
l'intérieur et l'extérieur sont qu'une
seule et même chose
l'autre de évidemment ne sert plus à
rien dans ces conditions la seule et la
vraie déflation à la guerre ma mission
est la suivante toute offre se compose
uniquement est essentiellement dexter
si telle était la façon de prisa volt
dont les shadoks définissait leurs oeufs
il faut avouer que les oeufs le leur
rendait bien aidé on faisait le plus
souvent qu'à leur secte
c'est ce qui explique pourquoi le
problème des oeufs avaient toujours été
chez les shadoks un problème mais qui
est si vivement problématique du premier
qui vous luttez clore il sortit il sorti
ce 6-3 il était raté le deuxième était
pas beaucoup mieux lui était pas
beaucoup le troisième est bien ma foi la
foi voilà
quand on vous disait que le problème des
yeux était un problème excessivement
problématique
vous en avez devant vous la preuve
vivante enfin pas tellement vivante que
çà et là qu'est ce qui avait bien pu se
passer
les premiers nés de la nouvelle
génération de shadocks lunaires sont un
peu raté voyons un peu comment se
présentent les autres et bien rassurez
vous les zones n'étaient absolument pas
présente à lui de ridicule petit bout de
shadocks de misérables vermicelles de
shadocks que dis-je vermicelles c'est
lamentable revenus de shadow oui c'est
tout ce qui sortait ce prometic
il avait bonne mine le ministre de la
population
lui qui avait promis à sa direction de
peupler la lune de shadocks conquérant
du chat d'oc vigoureuse et souriant de
shadocks populaire en somme
eh bien c'était raté cela était plutôt
disons impopulaire parce que saborder sa
s'agripper figurer mou ces sales bêtes
là bas il avait bonne mine avec sa
famille en pièces détachées pour mauvais
déploré avait bien essayé de se refaire
une famille présentable on veut recoller
les morceaux mais c'était même pas
standardisés enfin qu'est ce qui s'était
passé c'est que la pilule du professeur
chat deux coups voyez vous c'était bien
joli cela faisait pondre plusieurs à la
fois mais cela ne faisait pas pondre
plusieurs shadoks à la fois pour la
raison que nous allons essayer de vous
expliquer un oeuf normale a toujours un
intérieur bien à lui il arrive qu'un
mais me fais deux ou plusieurs intérieur
à lui tout seul c'est parra chez les
shadoks non seulement c'était pas pareil
mais c'était quasiment le contraire de
sorte que le même intérieur pour des
raisons d'un mur obscures se mettait
dans plusieurs zones et tonton d2 à la
ouais moi il y avait d'intérieur dans
chaque et moi il y avait des shadoks
c'était fatal
voilà ce qui s'était passé ça c'était de
la faute du chat d'oc population qui
avait pas surveiller ses intérieurs le
chat d'oc population peser finement
remarquer qu'il avait été nommé ministre
de la population seulement et pas
ministre de l'intérieur piètre excuse
et pendant ce temps là les shadoks
impopulaire a imperturbablement
continuer à explorer à un peuple et la
lune
tout n'était pas encore perdu voyez-vous
car shadow qu'on le brave professeur
shadow comme foire bien avoir une idée
géniale et va sauver la situation
avec la pilule du professeur shadow kyo
le ministre de la population a pondu des
shadoks en pièces détachées shadow qu à
une idée pour les rafistoler c'est
excessivement simple suivez mon
raisonnement carton de mater les sorties
de cette machine et par le truchement de
notre dévoué ministre j'obtiens des
shadoks en pièces détachées par
conséquent en réagi non les mauvais
shadoks côté pilule et en actionnant à
l'envers il doit sortir de notre
processus et j'adore ton pays et alors
que son fils de l'autre côté du mur
seules sorties
devinez quoi tu me pilule mais ne nous
affolons pas ne nous affolons pas là
nous avons plusieurs solutions première
solution nous ré administrons la pilule
aux ministres nous injectons langue et
nous obtenons voyons voyons un oeuf et
ministre et dont le à une autre pilule
mauvaise solution
deuxième solution injectons l'oeuf par
là les jeunes au concorso par là nous
avons une pilule est un ministre en a
déjà un très mauvaise solution
troisième solution la bonne suivez moi
bien et nous coupons la perle au morceau
nous la mettons dans les autres là les
impopulaires
nous injectons nous agitons et nous
avons encore une pilule et et c'est tout
eh bien c'est raté
et non ce n'était pas tout monsieur le
professeur et non ce n'était pas tout
car voilà que la machine
j'émettais a marché voilà qui s'est
débattue et qu'elle pourrait après les
pièces détachées et qu'elle les avaler
voilà quelle grosse fait qu'elles
grossissent est qu elle grossissait ont
un énorme tas d'os contest
un shadow contraire infernal déchaîné
famille qui tout à l'heure d'aller
manger la dernière-heure guichard
occassionnés ils vont mourir à cette
fois oui c'est bien lapin et tout ça à
cause des professeurs mais il n'y a une
quatrième solution cloud dont votre main
la pilule professeur la pilule dite
un shadok la chine avait englouti sa
pilule comme c'était justement une
pilule a coupé les shadows qu'on morceau
jadot qui s'écoule à un énorme tas de
détritus s'était finie et il peut encore
sauver cette fois là il s'en passait
quand même de drôles de choses sur la
lune
après la tragique affaire de la machine
à pilules qui a failli leur coûter la
vie les shadoks sont revenus à la
méthode de ponte classique
ce ne fut que petit à skis et quinquas
au rythme de clonage d'un chat d'oc qui
n'avait pas été fait pour ça que les
shadows que se repeupler
ils avaient bien du mal le ministre de
la population avec ses enfants il
grandissait pas vite car sur la lune en
ce temps là ils n'avaient pas grand
chose à se mettre sous la dent en
cherchant il avait trouvé un vieux harry
coûts qui restaient dans le tas de
détritus et qui passait son temps à ne
rien faire le haricot et pour nourrir
ses enfants ils voulaient cultiver des
haricots
alors le voilà qui plante son haricots
malheureusement la culture du haricot
sur la lune et quelque chose
d'excessivement dangereux à cause de
l'atmosphère qui met à l'intérieur vous
prenez part que dès que le haricot
commence à tousser d'affaires alors pour
la toiture et avoue penser c'est une
open et l'on profite aussi tout pour
aller se promener dans le haïku ou tout
autre d'aiguines qu'on peut mettre à sa
disposition
et voilà le haricot shadoks qui se
mettent à toulouse
à gonfler et la lune pendant ce temps là
naturellement à se dégonfler se
dégonfler bien tous les shadoks n'ont pu
rien à se mettre sous les pieds cette
fois là encore ils faillirent péri tout
ce qui reste est affaire s'était trompé
d'arrache-pied pour remettre
l'atmosphère dans la lune et tout ça
c'était de la faute aux shadoks
population qui encore quoi n'avait pas
fait son devoir mais parce qu'ils ont
des difficultés via les coûts dans le
ciel gégène ça le gênait énormément
aujourd'hui 7 et des réponses et puis
demain tu les shadoks sous le laisser
faire ça serait des carottes et des
navets tu souhaitais six poules et bien
à lui
ils en avaient assez et la lune ils
allaient l'abattre et manger des
derniers shadoks qui respect voilà ce
qu'il allait faire lui j'adore cas bien
tout était perdu
il aurait fallu partir dans les espaces
interstellaires à la recherche d'une
terre inhospitalière
mais avec quoi ils n'avaient même plus
une vieille fusée ni rien alors je long
le tout pour le tout les shadoks
décidèrent qu'il partirait quand même
qu'il partirait avec ce qu'il leur
restait sous la main c'est à dire qu'il
partirait dans le cosmos avec la lune
voilà harcelé par gégène les shadoks
risquons le tout pour le tout vont
partir dans le cosmos avec la lune pour
chercher une terres plus hospitalières
il allait s'enfoncer encore une fois
dans les profondeurs de l'espace et cela
si michel huys crever déglingue ira fils
tolly qui pouvait les laisser en plan
n'importe quand franchement c'était
risque
jadot qu'on avait mis au point un
système de propulsion et mère de son
invention
naturellement il fallait couper mais ça
la population s'en chargerait on bat les
malheureux shadoks prisonniers voyaient
d'un assez mauvais oeil vous pensez bien
leurs derniers espoirs de délivrance son
volume et sa qu'est ce que vous voulez
hein
c'est pas de notre faute il versait
runes dernières larmes sur cette terre
ce ne connaîtrai jamais et la population
put invités à pomper c'est alors que
commence à la difficulté
la population de pompey pas la
population le goulet a fait la
population refusait de poule
la population était sur le dos les pas
en l'air et s'en fichait telle mentalité
c'était donc ça la nouvelle génération
de shadocks lunaire des shadoks qui dont
ces jours où s'écrivaient des pages
parmi les plus grandioses de leur
histoire s'asseyait dessus mais ce
n'était pas de leur faute
les shadoks 9 était tombé malade il
avait attrapé le mal de lune le mal de
lune est une maladie universelle qui
s'attaque à tous mais dont on ne sait
rien sauf que cela se guérit près
simplement en tapant sur la partie
malade
c'est donc une maladie excessivement
pour le temps médical qui transige à un
grand ami mais là c'était beaucoup plus
bas le mâle de l'une s'était installé à
l'intérieur des shadoks et pour taper à
l'intérieur il aurait fallu un truc
spécial et ça on ne l'avait pas la
situation était rajic gégène
sans répit les bombarder la lui trouver
de toutes parts
couvrez et les shadows malade refuse
obstinément de pipe
tout semblait perdu mais j'adore nous
peut être pas le devin plombier avait
une idée il restait encore la légende
l'astral une shadoks ne peut pas partir
les shadoks 9 refuse de pompey pour leur
faire peur le devin plombier est allé
réveiller la légende en ce temps là on
est fait chez les shadows il n'y avait
une vieille d'une légende qui courent et
quand elle ne pourrait pas c'est qu'elle
était parti se coucher ou qu'elle était
tombé dans le fossé
ah ouais alors on l'attrapé assez
facilement le de 20 pompiers l'avaient
enfermé dans son robinet est il la
faisait parler le soir à la veillée
concert aux shadoks malades et les verts
ont op elle disait pas mal de bêtises et
elle disait 2-1 contre x sur la planète
shadow qu'il y avait un monstre un
monstre terrible qui n'avait qu'un oeil
et qui manqueraient tout ce qu'avait le
mal de lune
elle disait qu'il avait été condamné à
errer dans l'espace le monstre mais
qu'il avait jury revient à mme x ray et
c'est sur eux qu'il se vengerait s'il
voulait pas pompé voilà ce qu'elle
disait la vieille légende
et elle a ajouté que conte le monstre
revient à drake
et bien ce serait la fin du monde par
dessus le marché
mais ça c'était pas vrai c'était la
ville les gens qui a inventé les
vieilles légendes c'est comme ça plus ça
devient vieux plus là parlent à tort et
à travers mais les shadoks 9 une légende
aussi vieille que ça cela leur faisait
ni chaud ni froid
elle avait bien du mal alors pour lui
donner un coup de main le devin plombier
regarda dans son robinet machika matin
et s'écria je le crois il arrive il est
là le des bouées poupée c'est dans trois
jours la fin du monde mais les chaînes
donc neuf disait qu'elle s'en fiche et
attention puisque deux jours avant la
fin du monde et les shadoks neuf jeux
pour la dernière fois je vous le dis
pompey et craignez car c'est demain
manu monde et à la veille d'un si grand
jour les shadoks 9 rester couchés belle
mentalité
le soleil et la terre car on quitte au
temps et à la faveur de la nuit
silencieusement et pas à pas tout
doucement le lendemain approchait
et si la vieille légende avait dit vrai
les shadoks 9 atteint du mal de lune
refuse de pompey pour leur faire peur le
devin plombier et la vieille légende on
prédit la fin du monde pour aujourd'hui
le soi-disant dernier jour se levait
c'est aujourd'hui la famine de clamer le
plombier pomper malheureuse baisse vous
êtes ce soir vous mourrez mais la fin du
monde n'en finissait pas d'arriver et
les shadoks 9 vaquait à de bénigne
occupations comme si de rien n était ce
jour là il ne se passera rien de spécial
le lendemain non plus d'ailleurs on peut
dire que ce fut même une fin du monde
assez calme
[Musique]
même le devin pour s'acharner pomper
libérables bdd tiers laffanour un shadok
qui ne pompe pas est un chat document
les autres mais bon elle comme mauvaise
quoi révoltante qu'il était déjà mort
depuis hier et que chaque cours de la
veille shadoks le bon grain et l'ivraie
la fin du monde comme ça mais trouver
cela tout à fait à leur convenance et
s'était même dommage ajouté d'une
cyniquement qu'il n'arrive pas plus
souvent pour leur apprendre les bonnes
manières un certain nombre avaient été
condamnés à mort mais elle prétendument
il l'était déjà
cela ne leur faisait ni chaud ni froid
on était obligé de les condamner à mort
mais un perpétuité mais avec tout cela
un l'astre l'une d'avancer toujours pas
le grand départ shadoks vers l'infini il
semblait assez compromis car gégé qui
avait créé la pâte
la lune est de débarrasser la terre
dernier château estate gérer la foulée
de toutes les couleurs mais l'on
viendrait à bout de cette calamité
d'astro lune d'ailleurs il ne perd rien
pour attendre
est ce parce que de mémoire deux gènes
on ne connaissait pas d'exemple
d'aéroplan qui soit rester indéfiniment
au lait pour la cinquième ou sixième
fois la fin des shadoks apparemment
avait sonné alors comme tout semblait
perdu et qu'il n'y avait plus rien à
faire
les shadoks décidèrent à titre de
représailles et faute de mieux de
condamner aussi à mort la vieille maison
qui a démenti
la vieille légende qui avait prédit la
fin du monde et l'arrivée imminente du
monstre shadoks s'est trompé ne s'est
rien passé pour la punir les shadoks
vont la faire mourir leur du sacrifice
était arrivé à vieille légende petit à
petit se mit d'un succombé voilà c'est
fait alors il se fit dans le ciel un
grand bruit la lune chance là le soleil
et la terre s'obscurcit c'était la fin
du monde car c'est vrai c'était le
monstre qui revenait et pour la septième
fois lara des shadoks sauna et oui la
vieille légende avait dit vrai sauf que
bien sûr et s'était trompé d'une journée
mais qu'est ce que vous voulez c'est dit
légende c'est comme ça l'était plus
siffler le chat docteur ils avaient plus
envie de jouer au rouergue courrèges et
toi je vous prie de bois mais peine
perdue la fin du monde les poursuivaient
ça va car une terrible elle approchait
et d'approcher un moment la discipline
au diable baer le mouche un oeil
idem à l'état paraît
[Musique]
chalon peut sentir que leur fin et selon
lahcen habitudes qu'ils avaient en
pareille occasion il sera temps de se
pardonner les uns les autres leurs
péchés le monstre peu à peu émergé digne
et oui c'était nous c'était le vieux
marin shadoks d'autrefois
celui là qu'ils avaient banni de la
planète shadoks est condamné à errer
dans les espaces interstellaires erreurs
il les avait retrouvés et le voilà qui
arrive et se venger enfin et oui c'était
me le moose train un oeil que la légende
avait raconté à s'ils ne l'avaient pas
tuer la vieille légende
peut-être bien qu il ne se serait rien
passé voilà ce que c'est que depuis une
légende
[Musique]
le marin shadoks est revenu les autres
croient qu'il veut se venger et les
manger et fuit devant lui avec le race
trop long pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas le marin shadoks et qui pourrait
s'étonner de le voir se promener aussi
facilement dans les airs et disons qu'il
avait inventé un système de propulsion
interplanétaire à base d'eau on
l'apprenait à l'arrière pour la mettre à
l'avant voilà il fallait que tout cela
soit très synchronisée parce que si
c'est lyon avait ramène au plus vite que
ceux d'en bas la charia il n'y aurait
plus eu d'eau sous le bateau et il
aurait sombré
[Musique]
inversement si ce duo s'était arrêtée et
d autres pas l'on serait parti tout seul
et il aurait fallu courir après mais
pour passer en marche arrière avec ce
système là c'était une autre histoire et
en moyenne cela ne marchait pas dans la
marine ordinaire théoriquement pour
aller en arrière c'est bien connu il
suffit d'aller en avant mais dans
l'autre sens
cela s'appelle renversé d'amap on aurait
un peu renversé les shadoks qui servait
vapeur il n'y voyait pas d'inconvénients
mais il aurait fallu que l'on reste dans
les sauts et l'eau ou des raisons
excessivement obscurci opposer
formellement alors le bas-rhin shadoks
avec sacha doc caravelle il avait pas de
marche arrière
c'est des choses qui arrivent même à des
gens très bien élevés
aller toujours vers l'avant je note que
je n'ai pas particulièrement aimé me
disais que cela l'arrangé parce que de
toute façon qu'ils ne savaient pas où
ils allaient et sa vie faisait gagner du
temps de cars ajouté t-il
quand la marine c'est un principe quand
on ne sait pas où l'on va il faut aussi
aller et le plus vite possible
c'est dire que lorsqu'il traîné quelque
part c'était tout à fait par hasard et
pas spécialement pour se venger comme
les autres le croyait
depuis le temps qu'ils pour linguet
pouliné sur les mers cosmique
il avait été si souvent pris de boisson
qu'il avait oublié tout ça tu meurs
froid non non il ne voulait pas se
venger
non les shadoks il ne voulait pas les
manger c'est autre chose
thil prenait la shadoks caravelle
poursuit l'astro lune le marin essaie
d'attraper les shadoks
on ne sait pas encore où juste pourquoi
faire l'achat d'un bloc de caravelle
faisait merveille la plus franche en
s'entraîner avant dé chacun sous terre
[Musique]
il faut dire que la marine shadoks était
un bel exemple d'organisation
tout le monde était spécialisé les uns
étaient spécialisés dans le ramage les
autres et s'est spécialisé dans le
transport taz de l'eau et tout le monde
était content
tout le monde était contre 1 sauf
peut-être ceux qui étaient spécialisés
dans le battage
c'était sûr qu'on t'a fait quand le
marin avec des finitions à distribuer
c'était pénible évidemment mais c'était
indispensable pour maintenir le combat
de l'équipage car disait-il dans la
marine c'est un principe pour qu'il y
ait le moins de mécontents possible il
faut toujours taper sur les mêmes
c'est pourquoi il avait formé un corps
spécial le corps des shadoks à claques
envers lesquels il faisait très
habituellement preuve de la plus exquise
brutalité et bramais et ces bêtes là
vous courrez les essais comme de tout ça
finit toujours par suis et le corps
d'élite les shadoks à claques n'était
plus très présentable et il fallait
procéder à un échange standard
voilà pourquoi il voulait les attraper
de la lune engagez-vous dans les shadoks
à claques il criait vous verrez du pays
mais les hausses voulait pas pensé et ça
en faisait un vacarme cette sarabande
autour de la terre d'abord c'était la
lune qui pas cet engagement
cinq minutes après c'était le marin ses
pions pour la lune et puis encore le
marin ça n'allait pas bientôt finir tout
ce raffut il criait gêne on n'avait pas
et il s'amusait la nuit à des bêtises
pareilles
d'abord il avait commencé par balles a
dit la lune dans le ciel c'est la
semaine dernière c'étaient des haricots
et maintenant c'était des bateaux et
demain ça serait quoi encore à le
lendemain mais cinq minutes après c'est
et des autobus qui lui passait sur la
tête un geyser parce que les shadows
avait rien trouvé mieux que d'appeler
leurs vieux cosmo autobus à la somme
était trop dès demain s'était juré il se
débarrasserait le ciel de toutes ces
cochonneries tard
le marin shadow que courent après les
shadoks de la lune ceci pour fuir plus
vite ils ont appelé leur vieux cosmo
autobus nous n'allons pas essayer de
vous dire comment tu as un vieux cosmo
autobus faisait pour marcher rouler ça
serait une sage vraiment autres peintres
et vous expliquer comment l'astronome
marché s'était encore à ces choses là
shadoks arabe s était déjà un peu plus
compliqué pour le cos l'autobus alors là
il faudrait faire appel à des notions de
mathématiques shadoks tellement
compliqué que cela ne voudrais même pas
la peine d'essayer
nous essayerons quand même peut-être une
autre fois ci nous avons pour le moment
gégène a juré d'en finir une bonne fois
pour toutes avec ce manège là en
commençant par le barrage san roque qui
faisait le plus de bruit à chanter et à
taper sur ses chats d'oka classe qui
poussaient des cris d'orfraie les
pauvres mais jeunes vies tout de suite
que ça pouvait pas marcher parce que
vous comprenez tiré en l'air dans un
aéroplane par exemple ça va ça fait un
trou et l'ustensile ton métairie dont le
loup et à plus forte raison quand elle
est en l'air cela ne fait pas tout du
tout et rien de son fait gg n'avait été
demandé conseil à ses amis des gimmicks
ici que naissaient en artillerie
c'est très simple lui avait il dit fait
donc usage de thé dons naturels dont
naturel bien sûr que n'a qu'à siffler
sifflé eh bien oui quand gégène sifflets
vous vous souvenez il pleuvait et si
cela marche et avec des nuages gros
comme ça il n'y avait pas de raison que
cela ne marche pas sur les deux ou trois
malheureux saut de shadocks qui
soutenaient leur bateau eh bien oui cela
marchait l'on tombe à l'achat doc
caravelle tomba le marin les shadows
quatre lacs et les matelots tout ça
tombe adam loufoque larrazet exprès et
pour la première fois de sa vie
le pirate shadoks connu la mer 1 2 pour
lui c'était une nouvelle vie qui
commence est
et
[Musique]
gégène s'est débarrassé du marin shadow
que qui courait après les shadoks de la
lune le marin le bateau et ses matelots
sont tombés dans l'eau que ceux qui
craignent pour la vie du marin et de ses
matelots sera sur nos shadoks maritimes
ont été spécialement étudié pour vivre
on est des conflits à l'intérieur et
vers les plus uniques
il trouve même cela très agréable et
fêter leur nouvelle demeure de très
joyeuses façon
laissons si vous le voulez bien nous
voyons maintenant à leur humide séjour
pour faire un rapide tour d'horizon de
la situation extérieure
c'est avec un soupir de soulagement que
les shadoks de la lune avait vu le marin
tombé dans l'eau enfin ils allaient
pouvoir partir tranquille dans l'espace
à la recherche d'une planète plus
hospitaliers et malheureusement c'est
beaucoup car pour tout vous dire la main
d'oeuvre trompeuse shadoks n'était
absolument pas qualifié pour ça tout le
monde sait en effet que pour voyager
loin intersidéral mans parlant il faut
pomper autant et même beaucoup plus avec
la tête qu'avec les plis et la main
d'oeuvre shadoks la valeureuse n'était
absolument pas musclé de ce côté ce
qu'il leur fallait d'abord et avant tout
c'était une bonne main d'oeuvre
intellectuelle et pour ça on allait la
chaux mettre la main d'oeuvre un régime
spécial sévère et accélérer à base de
calcul concentrer plus de culture
générale sur activer de plomb théorème
comptable tôt axiome postulat bien gras
les quantités de machin comme ça
intellectuellement très nourris ce sous
la direction du professeur charcot la
future main d'oeuvre interstellaire
shadoks on faire un les cruelles et les
jbe
depuis le temps qu'on en entend plus
parler eh bien les jb les jbe sanaa les
pattes
très fort en réalité et si nous avons
laissé passé tellement de temps
justement son vous en parler c'est qu'il
se passait chez eux des choses assez
pénible que nous aurions préféré vous
cacher mais la vérité historique exige
que nous fassions notre devoir et nous
allons vous dira tout mais la prochaine
fois
les shadoks de la lune pour
intellectuellement gégé le fait son
jardin
les marins shadoks s'amusent comme des
poissons dans l'eau où il n'y a que chez
les gimmicks que cela ne va pas pourquoi
au début régime il avait trouvé la terre
bien amusante parce qu'elle tourne et
chaque fois que la terre faisaient un
tour ils faisaient une
[Musique]
en
il y avait la fête du premier tour qui a
commencé le matin aurait jusqu'au choix
il n'y avait ensuite la fête du second
tour qui n'était pas la même mais qui
durait tout autant et puis les fêtes du
troisième du quatrième du 5e tour et
ainsi de suite et un site
le reste du temps il réfléchissait à de
difficiles problèmes de botanique ou de
météorologie avec leur chapeau
mais à la fin à force de trouver des
solutions a tellement de problèmes
difficiles les problèmes même
commencèrent à se faire rares et les jbe
se disait des solutions on en a toujours
ce qui nous manque le plus maintenant ce
sont les problèmes et les gibiers à
travers une première maladie de la tête
il commençait rassemble
et puis n'est fait non plus au bout d'un
certain temps
ça ne les intéressait plus du tout
qu'est devenu tellement
un dollon qu'ils avaient chargé des
shadoks prisonniers de s'amuser à leur
place
il les regardait et ça leur suffit alors
il leur criais gégène on joue plus
aujourd'hui ça va pas ou quoi
si si ça va il me disait demain tu
verras on s'amusera et le lendemain à
arriver et au sable petit à petit ils
trouvèrent que les fleurs et les glace
au chocolat n'avait plus tout à fait le
même goût que les étés n'était plus
aussi bon contre x et que souvent il
faisait froid
petit à petit ils trouvèrent que les
feuilles sont plus souvent par terre que
sur les branches des marronniers les jbe
ne savait pas encore qu'il avait attrapé
une autre maladie de la terre une
maladie qu'il ne connaissait pas parce
que sur leur planète là bas c'était une
maladie qui n'existaient pas
il y avait que les jbe commençait à vide
et oui c'est des choses qui arrivent sur
la terre
non
les jb s'ennuie l'effet télé je ne les
intéresse plus à force de vivre sur la
terre petit à petit et sans s'en rendre
compte ils se sont mis à vieillir
tous les jours prennent est
lamentablement leur ennui et comme ils
ne trouvaient rien de spécial à faire
ils se préparaient des repas très
recherchée et ça donnait sans aucune
retenue à la gastronomie
[Musique]
[Rires]
à ce régime là vous pensez bien il
devint très rapidement gras et bouffi
[Musique]
ou essayer de maigrir
les malheureux faisait de la culture
physique et alors on les vit on les dit
non nous ne devrions pas d'autre choix
alors on vit triste et douloureux
spectacle on vit l'egypte icg autrefois
si intelligente petites bêtes se mettre
à faire du vélo à ramer et à pomper
imaginez-vous comme de vulgaires shadoks
france ont été trop et les shadoks
prisonniers qui étaient assez doué de
naissance pour ce genre d'exercice
servait de moniteurs et en profiter pour
se venger un peu vous pensé oh là là
quelle triste état que c'était là les
gibbons paix
il tombait comme ça pendant toute la
matinée à midi il fait chaud foyer et
l'après midi le suivait des traitements
appropriés
alors ça va pas il le crier gégène alors
on joue plus mais l'egypte y réponde et
qu'il travaillait le renvoyer chez lui à
grands coups lui dans le derrière à
week-end vous ville un spectacle c'était
mais rien n'y faisait plus le pomper
plus j me glisser glisser et couple il
s'est fixé une ligne à l'eau qu'à la fin
ils devaient encore plus vilain avec une
longue barbe et des poils mal planté que
commencer alors poussé partout et les
pauvres petits
vous savez toujours pas quelle maladie
l'avait attrapé les malheureux jbe sont
en train de vieillir ils deviennent gras
et bouffi pour ce faire maigrir il faut
de la gymnastique et suivent des
traitements spécialisés les jbe pompe
gégène
il n'avait plus d'amis pour vous offrir
de la musique cd mis lui aussi à faire
du vélo
déjà dense de la lune pourraient eux
aussi soit une chanson de cuir
intelligent et la terre pour suivre le
mouvement général elle aussi tournait
sur place
il n'y avait que le bas-rhin shadoks qui
continuaient à mener joyeuse bout et
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas tellement
[Musique]
les maquereaux shadoks s'adapter petit à
pied leur nouvel élément et se
transformait chacun selon son fou qui
ont jade en creux qu'un qui ont shadow
crabe mou château comme marion shadoks
haddock et tout ce petit monde bâton
j'ai le temps a dit vieux 8 à quai à ses
occupations habituelles
tout cela bien entendu se passer sous
l'eau évidemment pour que ça fasse plus
vrai on aurait pu mettre des algues du
rocher est petit plus les quantités de
tous les choses sous marine de cet
acabit mais pour nous vous comprenez ça
serait du travail
nos téléspectateurs sont quand même
assez grand pour s'imaginer tout seul
que cela se passe sous loue tout et ne
souffre façon cela n'ajouterait rien la
vérité de notre histoire il n'y avait
que la chaîne de caravelle qui
malheureusement n'était pas très habitué
à tout ça et fille commençait à battre
de l aile pour ainsi dire évidemment les
shadoks aurait pu tout bonnement la
laisser en plan et continuer à piller ou
par n'importe quel autre moyen de
transport sous marins plus approprié
mais voyez-vous dans la marine même sous
marines et des choses qui se font pas
alors pour ne pas qu'elles se gâte les
matches lyon avaient mis leur chat d'oc
caramel dans une grande bouteille et l'a
ramené à la surface de temps en temps
pour mes changer son aide
[Musique]
pour la nourriture et bien c'était
facile l'uma rachat d'hawk sous loire
est à la pêche
[Musique]
et quand arrivé le week end il en est où
se reposer à gg pic et dont c'est le
charleston jusqu'à une heure très
avancée de lattes les génies qui sont en
train de vieillir pompe pour se rajeunir
les shadoks de la lune avant de partir
dans l'espace suivent une formation
technique accélérer le calcul leur
avaient toujours donné pas mal de fil à
retordre étant donné qu'il ya des ces
quatre mots et qu'il ne pouvait pas
compter plus loin que 4 vous souvenez
mais le professeur chat de cours avait
réformé tout ça écoutons jean quand il
n'y a pas du chat d'oc ont dit gars et
on écrit quand il ya un shadok de plus
on dit but et on écrit quand il y en a
encore un chat d'oc ont disons et on
écrit
et quand il ya encore un autre on dit me
et on écrit tout le monde applaudissait
confort et trouvé ça génial a envie de
vaincre les utilisent et qu'on ne le
poly d'un soul que des enfants des
bêtises pareilles et que shadow qu'on
allait le condamner
sybille ses traits à poney les
mathématiques sont intéressés bien sûr
mais brûler le professeur c'était
intéressant aussi pour dire il est cité
à l'unm voter pour le laisser partir et
cool brûlerait après à l'arrivée à ce
réputé avec moi meuse ont pu gars qu'un
but so me crie après décaler le plombier
si je mets un shadok en plus évidemment
je n'ai plus assez de nous pour les
côtés alors ces prêts ça on les jette
dans une poubelle et je dis que j'ai
deux poubelles et pour ne pas confondre
avec le buzz du début je dis qu'il n'ya
pas de chat d'oc à côté de la poubelle
et j'écris plus gars on continue what he
jo poubelles et pas de chat d'oc à côté
si je mets un shadow qu'en plus il me
faut une autre poubelle
mais comme je n'ai plus de mots pour
compter des poubelles je m'en débarrasse
en des jetons dans une grande poubelle
j'écris but grande poubelle avec pas de
petites poubelles et pas du chat d'oc à
côté bus gas gas et on
continuez quand on arrive là et qu'on a
trop de grandes poubelles pour pouvoir
les compter et bien roulé mais dans une
super poubelle on écrit but gag haga et
on continue mais le 9e des triais que
tout ça c'était par terre qu'on allait
écrire un autre là sur la pancarte et
que si demain les écoliers n'est pas
trouvée compliquée dans sa pesée et bien
qu'on le brûle ré jusqu'au bout le
professeur tout ça semblait assez pâle
partait pour lui si d'ici notre
prochaine émission certains d'entre vous
trouvent comment ce nombre château que
s'écrit en français il serait bien
aimable de nous communiquer pour voir si
le nouveau système de numérotation
shadoks tenait debout nous vous avions
poser un petit problème voyons quelle
est la solution
il y aura un autre problème à la fin de
l'émission voilà le nombre shadoks
traduit en français beaucoup de nos
téléspectateurs avaient trouvé mais pas
mal de shadocks aussi il faut avouer et
oui le système du professeur shadow
comarch cet ex bannis des shadoks
maintenant avec montée grisé par le
succès le professeur continue son show
magistral et s'attaque aujourd'hui à la
réforme de la journée rochelle géométrie
shadoks reposer sur un postulat assez
bizarre qu'ils disaient la ligne droite
est le plus long chemin d'un point à un
autre et vous conviendrez que pour les
voyages interstellaires ça risquait de
poser des difficultés mais grâce à shen
de contout cela ait changé
ecoutons-le premier par le cloud
définition le point est la plus courte
distance possible entre deux lignes
première application étant données de
l'ign quelconque trouver l'endroit où
elle se coupe
supposons qu'ils se rencontrent zoé me
par exemple s'il en était ainsi d'après
notre définition la ligne zoho me serais
un point et serait plus courte que le
point but or ce n'est pas le cas donc
les lignes se rencontrent en bus d'où
théorème deux lignes qui se rencontrent
se rencontrent toujours au même endroit
propriétés remarquables tout ligne
prises hors d'un point ne passe pas par
ce point ou alors si ali passe c'est
vraiment par hasard
deuxièmement les points parallèle on dit
qu'un point est parallèle à deux autres
points lorsque ce point est en cours n'a
blement disposer si on le déplace d'un
côté ou de l'autre
il est plus parallèle d'où théorème la
condition suffisante pourquoi points
restent bien parallèles à deux autres
points et qu'il reste là où il est et
qu'il ne bouge pas en deuxième partie
d'année on appelle ligne de premier
choix lénine qui ne passe que par des
points parallèle on appelle l' in shadow
coup ligne encombrante les lignes qui
passe plusieurs fois par un même point
ou par plusieurs on appelle ligne de
deuxième catégorie des lignes qui arrive
sur un point qui s'arrête on appelle
ligne deux dernières catégories ou
petites lignes les lignes qui ne passe
que par un seul point
[Musique]
et maintenant à petit exercice de
mathématiques shadow si le chat 2 que
pour moi le long d'une ligne de premier
choix parcours des shadoks mettre à
l'heure combien mettra-t-il de temps
pour parcourir tour joker
la réponse dans notre prochain numéro
les jb vieillissez bout fils les shadoks
de la lune et c'est de se développer le
cerveau mais d'abord voyons quelle est
la solution de notre dernier problème de
mathématiques shadow est reçue de nos
fidèles téléspectateurs et charmante
téléspectatrices quantité de réponses
qui malheureusement sont hautes sources
de sorte que personne n'a gagné le
voyage sur la lune que d'ailleurs nous
ne vous avions pas promis le problème
posé était le suivant un chaton partout
shadoks mettre à l'heure combien
mettra-t-il de temps pour parcourir 11
shadowplay
et bien il mettra un ton infinie
les onze shadoks m il ne l'est pas
recours à jamais parce que le chat d'oc
que nous a montrée malheureusement au
bout de dix admettent qu'ils tombent
complètement épuisé
mais revenons à notre histoire mais on
appétit par les délicieuses enseignants
du professeur jadot co les shadoks de la
lune ce livre est maintenant et sont
désemparés à une véritable omri de
culture
alors leur tête petit à petit celui par
me wade
on fera donc le reste aux négriers
mais chris et mara des shadoks mulet et
oui il mettait tant et si bien que leur
corps finit par disparaître complètement
pendant que la tête de son côté se
garnissent et de fat a pas on avait un
chat d'oc
rien qu'en tête qui ressemblait un
château cortina peut-être mais qui était
garanti 100% culture éducation la lune
ou enfin allez partir avec à son bord la
fine fleur de la civilisation shadoks
qui allait répondre à travers l'espace
les bienfaits de la château culture
c'était pas beau ça assis alors que c
est vous
et encore une fois ce fut le départ les
shadoks à grosse tête sont priés de se
mettre en selle les responsables quant à
eux prendrait place dans le cosmos au
but c'est de loin superviserait les
opéras 3 mais les autres étaient pas du
tout on n'avait pas poursuivi de l'un
des véhicules et à des loups encore qu
on en arriver là et que c'était deux
qu'ils allaient superviser le brillant
décidément commencer l'assemblage la
cosmo l'une va partir au dernier moment
les shadoks à grosse tête ont pris la
direction des opérations et ont obligé
les responsables à pompe et à leur place
[Applaudissements]
c'est ainsi qu'un matin il ya bien
longtemps la lune et les shadoks
critères la terre cahin caha temps pour
aller mon principe vers l'infini et même
plus loin si c'était possible
[Applaudissements]
l'équité sans aucun regret une terre qui
était loin de leur avoir procuré un
tendre que sa phrase et la terre les dix
partis de la même façon
le train interstellaire shadoks
comportait première non un module en
forme de cosmo autobus ou les shadoks la
grosse tête faisait des calculs derrière
venaient la lune qui servait des tâches
propulseur par le show du cirque shadox
du vin plomberie du professeur tad oct
tout cela est parfait et au moins de
rien le drain shadoks tête l'orbité
terrestre pour se placer sur la
trajectoire de voyage de forme
approximativement shadow koïta à ce
moment là comme vous le savez les usages
en astronautique de se débarrasser de
laitages propulseurs qui pratiquement ne
sert plus à rien les shadoks à grosse
tête sont parfaitement au courant de
tout ça un appui la route tous les
tâches propulseur évidemment régine
prothèse in dans le tout de même pas les
laisser en plan perdu là en plein mieux
l'espace c'était pas humain la technique
c'est la technique dévoile a condamné à
mourir ici un tout au moins à y rester
jusqu'à la fin des siècles
triste fin
mais depuis le temps qu'il faisait
pompes et les autres après tout hein
ils n'ont que ce qu'ils méritent et une
autre histoire de ce point de vue là ce
n'est pas tellement qu'il morale que ça
pendant ce temps là sur la terre les
jours passaient et comme ces usages et
les jbe continuer à pied
et un jour mais certains failli mourir
alors l'egypte y compris qu'il y avait
encore sur la terre un problème qu'il
n'avait pas résolu qu'il fallait faire
quelque chose mais vite sans quoi des
jbe une ligne on aurait bientôt plus
à
les shadoks à grosse tête ont laissé
leurs trois chefs en plan et continue
tout seuls dans leurs costumes autobus
sur la terre d'egypte ils ont enfin
montré qu'ils ont attrapé une terrible
maladie c'était la maladie de la terre
qui fait mourir des choses et les chants
une maladie que les jurys ne connaissait
pas car il venait d'une planète où le
temps n'existait pas ou plutôt le temps
allait et venait d'un côté et de l'autre
de sorte que c'était toujours mais même
si bien qu'ils servent les cheveux qui
n'avait pas ce genre de problème là il
n'y en avait pas mal qui périssaient
mais il y en avait aussi pas mal qu'il
est certes et cahin caha avec des who et
des balles dans l'eau très bon an mal an
la population shadoks aller plus ou
moins sont chez les jb malheureusement
ce n'était pas prévu
la seule façon de guérir c'était de
rentrer chez eux mais vite sans quoi ils
seraient 30 à l'egypte bigras tombe bien
que mal s'entassent dans leurs fusées le
cosmo code 999 et activer la fusée jbe
et la fusée libye et la cuisine j 10
noeuds parc
[Musique]
il était drôle ou pas beaucoup trop
lourd mais trop lourd tout de même un
bon il y avait un vide tôt
comme il est d'usagé en pareille
occasion il fallut bien tirés au sort
qui allait rester et le son combat sur
un gibier que vous avez oublié peut-être
le jpy qui autrefois avait perdu son
chapeau dans l'espace et était devenu
fou à cause de cela mais la jarre du
risque aussi bien les choses car ce jbe
faut justement n'avait pas attraper la
maladie de la terre et tout laissait à
penser qu en y restant élevé est plus
jeunes promis que de toute façon ne s'en
occuperait et la fusée jbe parti et le
parti
mais lentement lentement mais au fur et
à mesure qu'il s'éloignait et que la
planète jbe approchait leurs biens poil
petit à petit disparaît c'est quand il
arriverait peut-être serait-il qui rit
tout à fait la cosmo lune et le cos moto
bus sont quelque part dans l'espace
l'egypte vit pour échapper à la maladie
de la terre sont parties in extremis en
laissant lui libye fou à la garde de
légers il faut dire qu'on devenant vieux
l'egypte y était devenu un peu méchant
et c'était sans aucun regret qu'il
décèle à l'un des leurs ah il est loin
le temps où l'on vous disait les gibiers
et et de petits animaux très gentil avec
un petit chapeau sur la tête pour
pouvoir se tenir pour il était très très
intelligent intelligent il n'était
toujours mais du côté de la gentillesse
alors là vraiment il était grand temps
qu'ils retournent chez eux se refaire
une santé
les jbe partie la terre calme et sereine
en devint la planète gêne qu'elle avait
toujours été gégène tous les matins elle
gbe fou à gg and beach s'amuser voyais
aller si vous vouler savoir on part de
la place gégène qui est bien déserte
maintenant
on suit la buvette du long jusqu'au fond
pour gène un peu plus loin vous verrez
on bute sur une rivière où la traverse
des gènes la rivière et on la longe le
temps d'une cigarette ou deux quand on
arrive au carrefour gégène au lieu de
tourner à gauche on colle raccourcie par
les dunes à travers des oyats et
l'église net et on tombe sur la plage gg
devenu depuis gégène ce match
quand vous irez vous reconnais nosy be
s'amuse est un peu sur la plage
construisait des châteaux il faisait des
pâtés mais vous voyez bien qu'on font
ils s'ennuient et quelquefois quand les
terres étaient hautes sur l'eau
le soir quand la fraîche tombée vous
pouvez voir les sous-marins shadoks
version passe pour danser le charleston
et faire du ski noté
il jouait et perdez des fortunes
colossales d'or et de diamants de mer
qui ne valaient rien dans des casinos
qui n'existait pas encore il joue pas
est facile et sans nous
un jour djiby dit je vais aller à la
pêche aux crevettes
tu sais lui dit gentil mot gégène c'est
un peu tôt dans la saison
des crevettes il n'a pas encore sur la
terre
mais ce soir là ne jbe fou ne revint pas
de la pêche aux crevettes
la terre est redevenue calme il ne reste
que les marins shadoks dont l'objet
n'est le gibier abandonné
malheureusement il est parti à la pêche
et il n'est pas revenu il n'était pas
revenu car il était tombé au creux d'un
rocher sur une sorte de taverne de fond
de mer où les marins shadoks attendait
joyeusement la marée on joue au poker
le jpy leur avait raconté ses malheurs
qu'il était tout seul et qu'il voulait
rentrer chez lui sur sa planète
quelle planète et qu'il en connaissait
l'une des planètes des petites des
moyennes des grandes comme ça n'est le
gie be ne savait pas alors sur la fin de
l'après-midi les shadoks requins ont
ramené le petit sur la plage avec le
flou et la gégène leur a dit que c'était
un gibier abandonné et il leur a raconté
la malheureuse histoire
les shadoks requin ou pleuraient et le
marin shadoks fut saisie d'une sainte
colère que c'était scandaleux
on n'avait pas idée d'abandonner les
gens comme ça eh bien il allait leur
montrer les bonnes manières à ses
cousins 600 keur des tresses cnra et ça
crie pour le jury oui il irait lui sur
la page dit il ramènerait le petit et il
tirait au jour une bonne correction par
la même occasion
[Musique]
ça c'était une jolie mais pour partir
dans le cosmos et remettre la shadow
caravelle en l'air c'était une autre
affaire gégène heureusement connaissait
un endroit un endroit secret ou le
cosmos ont ce temps-là est descendu
assez bas et d'où l'on pouvait sortir de
la terre comme je voulais c'était une
montagne de montagne si honte que les
choses à son sommet tenait en l'air
toute seule et s'envolait l'heure du
départ était arrivé là shadoks caravelle
est lancé tu as pourtant discours sont
échangées loin bon ben voilà at il oui
voilà répond gégène voilà voilà le film
est bien aller ensemble
oui c'est le alors au revoir à crier
gégène et on le vit pendant très
longtemps faire des cimes lillois c'est
ainsi que ce jour-là il y as traître
les derniers j'adore qu'est le dernier
gibier quittèrent la terre et c'est
ainsi que notre histoire finit en
principe c'était il ya très très très
longtemps
en ce temps là un beau matin le dernier
shadoks quitte à la terre et repartir là
d'où ils étaient venus
c'est à dire assez loin ce qu'il arriva
ensuite ma foi nous n'en savons rien
les manuscrits shadoks authentique en
effet s'arrête là et nous sommes bien
obligés de nous arrêter aussi mais nous
avons quand même pu à travers le temps
et l'espace entrer en contact avec notre
correspondant permanent sur la planète
shadoks auxquelles nous allons poser
quelques questions si vous le voulez
bien
monsieur chat d'oc vous m'entendez c'est
formidablement quoi monsieur chat d'oc
est ce que vous êtes aussi idiots qu'on
le dit mais pourquoi un brin mais
combien de temps le resterez vous pouvez
bien voilà qui est parfait et j'en suis
bien contente pour
comment me demande encore comment la loi
et que pensez-vous de la terre
oui avec eux s'ils voulaient à ouïr moi
mais c'est pas exactement ce que vous
m'aviez dit tout à l'heure un oui oui
vous avez aussi vous beaucoup de malades
[Musique]
mais c'est tout c'est vraiment
passionnant tout ça mais nous risquons
de déborder il faut que nous avons
l'antenne si vous le voulez bien nous
reprendrons c'est intéressant entretien
demain
bon eh bien nous allons reprendre là où
nous en sommes restés dans notre
histoire
que sont devenus le marin shadoks le
cosmo autobus les jbe et la cosmo lune
après avoir quitté la terre c'est pas
très clair enfin je vois qu'il vous
reste un film là sur votre bureau vous
tournez-vous le passé allait-on shadow
ah oui évidemment c'est embêtant oui
mais je peux traduire vous savez j'ai
l'habitude d'accord la shadoks caravelle
fendait l'espace et la terre peu à peu
disparaissant au bout de cinq à six
semaines on a perçu par le travers une
cave qui dérive
c'était la lune avec les trois
malheureux shadoks abandonné qui
pleurait comme des madeleines des pour
deux jours après c'était le cos autobus
et les shadoks à grosse tête ont repêché
[Musique]
et puis après devinez qui et oui les gy
be
il était tombé en panne 2 au 6 mai comme
le barrage adore qu'on n'avait pas de
rancune et que de toute façon il avait
oublié il et son valet jbe aussi par
dessus le marché
[Musique]
et comme toutes ces aventures là les
avait pas mal fatigué ils décidèrent les
uns et les autres qu'ils iraient en
vacances se repoussent le marin dit
qu'il connaissait justement une planète
exprès pour ça où il faisait toujours
beau et toujours chaud
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que les shadoks élégie be un
jour il ya très très longtemps prirent
le chemin de la planète vacances et mire
le cap sur le solaire
et le marin qui les avait tous sauvés
terminal histoire sur une de ces
vieilles maxime dont il avait le secret
c'est encore dans la marine qu'il y a le
plus de na
oui
[Musique]